but the Dalai Lama talks about kind of a  pyramid for the basis of the pyramid is  moral living figure out write down what  your moral values are and make a plan to  live according to the step one learn  your values act according to values  practice your values write it down  Journal it step two is build a  meditative practice build a practice of  contemplation maybe that's formal  meditation maybe that's walking in the  woods but you need a practice without  devices where you can be a piece and  make sure you start with at least 15  minutes a day and finally you need to  read wisdom you need to you expose  yourself to people who have had deeper  thoughts and more profound thoughts than  you in whatever tradition you want and  do that daily for at least 15 minutes  starting there your life will change it  will your world will rock